yo what's up everybody it's the one and
only TK Kirkland check me out on the
boot Lake cev podcast y he's the one and
the original peace hey about to get into
a new interview want to shout out to our
sponsor Imperial they're giving you a
free that's right free two G top shelf
pre-roll with the glass tip that's right
delivered right to your door all right
it's free all you got to do is pay
shipping use the promo code bootleg at
Imperial extraction.
there's a 1.5 gram of Premium flour plus
a half a gram of thca diamonds loaded up
in this thing and guess what you could
get one for free with the promo code
bootleg go to Imperial extraction. comom
it's free you just pay shipping let's
get into the
interview ble C podcast special guest
here at TK Kirkland ladies and gentlemen
he's
back TK I gotta tell you uh I went and
saw you at the ice house and it's the
first time I saw your stand up live in
person yes oh my God it was just just
amazing thank you so much I appreciate
you my man it was good to see you there
laughing too I was dying and and and I
finally saw your significant other and I
see why you married beautiful young lady
and then you know it's funny cuz if you
take your lady or your significant other
to a TK show you're going to laugh and
your girl might look at you like m mm
mhm that's so true that's so true you're
so right it's so right yeah but I I I'm
I'm glad that you came out it was really
good look for sure I really appreciate
that um it's crazy too man cuz I feel
like uh more than ever comedy everyone's
talkinging about comedy isn't that a
great thing shout out to Cat Williams
show some love shout shout out to cat
for bringing um comedy to the Forefront
of entertainment and if you've been
around a long time you know you only get
10 minutes in this game so you got to um
capitalize off this because next week
it'll be something else yep right for
sure next week or something he's had a
Choco the first couple weeks of first
couple weeks the New Year CU you know
puffy happy you know Puffy's happy yeah
cuz that we we not talking about him no
more lot of people are happy yeah
everybody happy Jo y everybody's talking
about something else so it's it's a good
moment no for sure when you saw the
interview cuz I don't know if you
watched all of it cuz I've been any of
it so what I did was I talked to
different people and I saw different
clips and I was able to seg way and put
my own it's a lot it's two and a half
hours yeah two so I did my own thing on
it but when at first I had one opinion
mhm what was that first opinion the
other opinion was I felt I didn't like
um Shannon sharp allowing cat to talk
about everybody because as a man I felt
like yo we don't do that on this show
you're supposed to stop him as a man
that's how I move but then someone told
me not t those people went on those
shows prior to him coming which is
almost why he wanted to go on exactly
and and they talked about him and that's
what it started so then they got what
they deserve yeah it was kind of like
fair game at that point yeah absolutely
I'm here to defend myself as and retort
everything that has been said on the
same platform so when I saw that I I I I
respected that and I I left it that way
how much of uh what cat was saying would
you say is you know entertainment
inflated and how much of it because I
feel like that there was there was
enough truth in there for people to get
to to talking but I feel like there was
also certain stuff like yeah I would say
99% of it was um inflated right
especially the running the running the
40 a I think I talked about it on stage
about stage because used to run track
right I used to run track like you know
and and and and if people don't know
something well you running track at seon
out here I sure was yeah and I was on my
way to the Olympic trials at when I was
out here wow and the thing about um
track and people don't know it you
believe almost anything and I tell
people Cass said he could run a 44 at 50
years old and I said Dion Sanders who
was one of the fastest people in the
world ran a 41 when he was 2 something
years old right and C said he ran that
fast with sweats on as a 50y old man as
a 50y old man just don't add up so I put
20,000 on the BET out there to to race
cat now it's not going to be a fast race
but you'll win I'll win it's not going
to be a fast race if if if people saying
44 is fast me and Cat literally probably
run a 40 yard dash
and
seven 7 69 maybe 73 74 that's my
prediction and yeah I mean you're the
expert so I don't know how yeah cuz I'm
63 years old so a 63 you not running a
for something it's impossible or at 50
or 50 is impossible you same bolt maybe
when youan Bolt's 50 maybe maybe maybe
maybe right yeah as 50 60 years old you
ain't running that fast um talk about uh
a few of the things you were saying on
stage that I was that that I I one of
the things I wanted to talk to you about
was something that i' heard I've been
hearing a lot more people who are more
um I guess uh financially illiterate
than me okay talk about
how to leverage life
insurance good question my man well the
insurance game is really um because I'm
very confused about it but I've heard it
so many times and people who I know
they're like yeah you know you can get
taxfree money like like so see it's it's
a lot of levels of the tax right so
let's take whole life insurance M whole
life insurance if you created a policy
you call your whoever your agent is your
State Farm and you say hey I want to
open up a whole life insurance policy
let's just take 100,000 you put 100,000
in and over course of time that money
will grow so fast that you become your
own bank so let's say now you only got
100,000 I say you got 200,000 but you
want to take 75,000 out to buy a car put
itest in business house whatever you can
do that and they won't tax you on the
money what they do is you'll still pay
what you're paying on that um policy but
when you die it comes out they take it
off the top oh so you're almost like
borrowing from yourself after you die
exactly but it's taxfree
exactly that's whole life insurance and
they and these are things I think they
should teach you in school right yeah
because at any given time if an
emergency happens or you have a business
opportunity present itself and you might
think to yourself well I don't have it
you don't have it but if you had this
Dam so let's say you get a $100,000
insurance policy life insurance policy
and you want to take 5,000 out 10,000
you don't have to pay that back they
they'll take it when you when you die as
long as you keep paying your policy you
got to keep paying the policy you got to
keep paying the policy but you can do
that do people like can you have
multiple multiple life insurance polies
oh yeah yeah for sure some you like um
Derek Jeter has a policy on everybody
and his
family I mean I feel like it I feel like
when you hear that out loud it sounds
bad unless you know why right but it's
it's it's smart and people are are
afraid to take out insurance good
especially some men if if your wife or a
daughter saying Dad we should take out
insurance some people say no because you
don't want to make the other person Rich
you don't want the other person that's
the mindset of most people but in
actuality people are afraid to create a
legacy you have to have a legacy to and
that's one of the best ways Insurance to
do that if you have but then structure
it too because when you get free money
you're going to run through it yeah I
mean I think that that's that's why most
people they turn 18 they get a credit
card exactly if you leave anybody any
money and they didn't work for it unless
they have true discipline or very very
frugal they running through it yo cuz
they never had that kind of money at one
time yeah cuz I know some people will
set up like a trust to pay out your
family once you're you're there right
yeah you certain amount or you got or
you got to do something like you got to
go to school you got to get a degree and
then you're going to get this payment
exactly y you have to structure it but
I've know people that got
millions and ran through it in couple
years it's crazy one of my female
friends and
um she inherit one .2 million less than
a year and a half it was all going you
know how answer was I had a good
time but now what exactly but now what
and I'm glad you brought that up cuz the
world needs to hear this you know and
then you got a thing called term life
insurance and term life insurance is
like about nine years you know but you
pay on it every month you need it's
protection you want to be you want no
man should be walking the street without
some sort of insurance just in case you
die you don't want to put that burden on
your family you know so you have term
life insurance but the clever thing
about term life insurance is after 9
years they gave you every dime back it
was like a savings account and that's
called surrender you they'll send you
something in the mail because you
because you you're alive yeah they they
they have they send this in the mail say
you can surrender your account and they
send you you could fill out the forms
they send you back all that money every
time can you borrow against the ter no
you can't borrow against that but that's
just something that is in of you putting
does it grow in that it doesn't grow but
you're protected but imagine years n
years you put something in the in and
also that money isn't it's yours if if
you don't die you're getting it back yes
and and and if you don't want to be
insured anymore right so so let's say
six years in you're like you know what
I'm good I need my money back no no no
that can't won't do it that way they'll
tell you when it's time to they want you
to surrender your account you can't tell
them you can't say I got this money here
it's not a bad idea to do a version of
both yes yeah yes so the insurance thing
and you want to have burial insurance
and so is that for when you pass your
there's one thing there's life insurance
you can Buri Insurance burial insurance
is strictly for the funeral right but
then you let the people who you love you
could take that or you could take the
money out of the life insurance policy
and pay for the burial um my kids is all
set up you know I got my stuff that one
I'm not having a funeral so I'm getting
cremated boom I don't want to even a
service you so you've already thought
about all that no yeah most lot of
people don't know your grandparents at
least people Grand I know have their
whole funeral and everything set up that
so for you you'd rather be pre-med and
then have your a spread or it's either
either cremation or I want my I want my
ashes to become a tree oh yeah or you
put my whole body in the ground and this
this thing I forgot about my daughter
said and I could grow as a tree and you
you're in a certain place so I'm gonna
do something unique and different
but I feel like a funeral is like a vain
thing to think about having because like
because you're not there you're not
there but you know who did it the best
in my lifetime who Queen
Elizabeth it was on TV yeah you saw how
H funeral was did you even look at it a
little bit I saw some of it listen to me
it was the greatest thing I've ever seen
in my life it was masterful I think that
funerals help families grieve that's
true cuz it brings everyone together and
you know it it helps it let me tell you
how I look at it I lost my mother my dad
and all my brothers before I was 40 MH
I've been to so many funerals you you it
drive your head crazy as I've gone
through life you know people invest in a
lot of things right people invest in
gasoline Tesla stock and all that I want
people to invest in their time time is
the most precious commodity that you
have that's taken for granted for sure
and when I pass I'm I'm giving the world
a gift what I'm saying to you don't come
to my funeral this time that you
have continue doing what you're doing
just take a moment to say t to the mfk
right and keep it moving because I don't
it's I'm not saying that I want to waste
your time right I just understand how
powerful time is and that's my gift to
the people I want them to
um really take their time seriously cuz
could you imagine IM if everybody had a
dollar for all the time that they wasted
it is crazy and and the amount of things
that we can waste our time on now is
greater than ever yes cuz there's a
terminology most people don't use called
um time wasters we all have met them mhm
people in our life wasting your time
yeah we always met somebody that was a
time waster right it's crazy someone who
doesn't respect your yes yeah it happens
yeah I got a few of those people mhm so
when I do business on the phone what I
do is for someone someone is talking to
me about doing a show yo before we hang
up the phone you got to send me $2 to
$5,000 that way I know you serious
you're not getting off the phone with me
and I picked up that call and you going
about your business you decide you going
to do something else cuz you wasted my
time and it also makes sure that when
people reach out to me they're prepared
they already know what it is a lot of
men lot of people don't know they're not
prepared when they call you they'll say
oh I'm thinking about no I'm not the
person you think about when you called
me you should have been known what
you're doing we're doing this or we're
not doing yeah yeah don't play with me I
do your homework and then call me right
then do your homework then call me yeah
I'm too busy and I stay booked well I
was going to say you you mentioned this
on stage obviously you did the Ice House
for the first time ever yeah first time
ever which it's a legendary comedy venue
it's been open 60 some odd years um but
you were kind of you gave us a peek a
bit into like the business side of your
deal you get a n you get 90% of the door
90% which I think what cuz coming from
the music world we just think of an
artist they get booked they get their
money they get their backend then they
leave yes however the show does however
the show does but you you're structuring
it to where you're ESS you're the
promoter I'm actually the promoter yep
I'll put up the money for he the venue
is going to make their 10% and then
they're going to make their food and
their liquor and all that ex yep exactly
but you're going to be able to get your
ticket I'll be a to get my money back
that I spent to put in for
advertising um and I've always been that
way so when I see um is that pretty
common no okay most um artists feel I
think in the music industry you got to
have an agent because the book you inv
venue but in comedy you you need people
to help you it's just that me you you
you know me and my son right you know
how we move so I'm just a guy who over
the years made relationships I mean you
can call most of these club Owners at
this point oh yeah easily and that's
exactly what I do and I book myself
years in advance like literally right
now I'm booked for the next 10 years
that's crazy that's insane and I've been
like that my whole career I always I
always got to know what I'm doing next
year I feel like watching you cuz I feel
like we get so much of you through
podcasts yes but I feel like you have to
have a special on Netflix or something
it's coming because I by watching you
bro like I've seen everybody live I'm a
comedy nerd so I'll go to the store and
if if one of my if a comedian's in town
that I like pay and I'll go watch it you
know but watching you live I was like yo
this is like as much as it's hilarious
and I'm crying out of my eyes I like
left with like I like how you you
finished but then you
said everyone hang out for another 10
minutes so I can give you guys some game
cuz you you had hit your like your your
last joke but you were like we're going
to hang out but it was very much like
kind of like a it was like it was like a
mixture of like you know life coaching
and a standup and I love and I love that
and when anybody sees me that's exactly
what they take my high school coach who
loves everybody from Red Fox down to
Dave Chappelle he said he saw my who
raised you
special he said TK I've seen them all
there's nobody like you so I took the
long rout in sense um I'm I'm doing
Netflix because of people like yourself
let me explain to you why I have my own
network called tk. Network right and I
have my own I don't have many as catw
Willams but I have my own specials did
my own thing did very very well and I'm
going to I'm going to do Netflix and I'm
working on it now like my deal with Live
Nation is set up for me to do my Netflix
special and when I do my Netflix I'm
going to do something really unique um
my goal now is to um I never did any of
ice cu's movies but I want ice CU to
direct my because I started out with
inwa right I want to use baby because he
took me on the Cash Money Rough Rider
tour I want to use Dr Dre um as one of
the producers I'm gonna give all them a
check because I came up through hip-hop
I didn't come up like the Chris rocks
and the um Kevin you you were working
out on stage in front of a hip-hop crowd
right I was in front of a hip-hop crowd
20,000 30,000 in the '90s right when we
was at when hip-hop was at the top of
the game and when I do this Netflix
special I wanted to be so unique and so
amazing that it has the same effect of
what you just said that when you leave
there or when you watch it you go what
did I just witness and I don't have to
do nothing special all I got to do is
just be me and that's what's going to
come across yeah it's crazy too cuz I
feel like uh nowadays more people are
trying to do comedy than ever because
it's so easy to get access to like I
could do a bit and it might not work if
I'm doing it at an open mic but if I
record it and I make it real out of it
with captions it might work online right
which is happening a lot but I feel like
the the number one thing is the same
thing with music is the stage presence
you got to have your delivery like you
had a guy open for you who I thought was
okay but the host that was hosting your
show was so good yes and what was
different about him than the other guy
was I just felt like the presence of
like like he could have said anything
and I would have laughed if that makes
sense you know what I'm saying he was
hilarious delivery presents but like to
me that's kind of like for you it's like
like you command that stage man and yeah
that's and that's one thing I do know I
have I have um what they call stage pres
yeah yeah I definitely have that so I
love it um coming through this week
doing the different clubs and having
everybody come out to see me was is was
a true blessing and because the last
since the last time I seen you I have
skyrocketed on the in the media game
social media right this went on a whole
another level
and um I just really found my Niche and
just really waking up in the morning
giving my opinion on something right no
I've seen you post like you you have
your quotes and it have my quotes and
man it just really takes off but in
actuality I'm
just you know me for a while I'm just
really just being me and people find
that fascinating so I'm just going to
run with it see what it does you said
something uh that is was this a true
story where you said you you were you
were taking care of a young lady she had
a place was it in Chicago she had a
condo right and you showed up and you
were cracking jokes and some dude was
laughing under the bed is here's the
here's a great thing about those type of
jokes yeah it's like a magician who
can't tell his the secret to Magic that
makes sense you know what I mean so I
want people to leave is that true right
or is that a a real joke but then say
you got to really be clever to come up
with something [__] was so good yes
thank you um talk to me about where like
like do you even like pay attention to
other standup like if Dave if Dave
Chappelle drops a special which he
dropped on New Year's did you check it
out I didn't check it out I know he's
funny I I catch Dave and most comedians
in bits and pieces but I always had this
rule never watch another comic
perform because when they're good you're
going to actually take something that
they without even thinking about
itous subconscious so when I see
comedians watching me it hurts because
they don't know the rule because I know
my stuff is funny and if you watch me I
know you're going to take something in
my flip it and U break it down as much
as possible but you got it for me um I
know you had said before that uh you
you've had some bits stolen is yeah yeah
yeah yeah I had a um um in my days of uh
younger days I used to do a thing called
things questions series of questions and
matter of fact we we've been trying to
find it I did it on the apolla I did it
everywhere and it was a series of
questions I go um why a lucky child so
magically delicious and where is The
honeycom Hideout is it downtown and why
do old people walk so early in the
morning do they have somewhere to go and
it was like a series they got me it got
me a standing ovation in um at the
Apollo in New York city so what I told
people that Arin Hall and all his staff
they took that bit flipped it and made
it things that make you go H and I told
people that my Foundation of that
material went on to make people hundreds
and hundreds thousands of dollars and
what I mean by that is Arenal Hall did
it but if you Google there was a group
called CNC Music Factory that did a song
that things to make you go H then crafts
and macaroni and cheese also did a
commercial and they used the cheese as
it was melting and in the background the
song was things that make you go home
saying that they macaroni and cheese was
so delicious it will make you go H all
that came from TK and I just never I
just never tripped about it but I moved
different than most people for sure for
sure you're not I mean you're not Petty
I'm not Petty yeah I'm not Petty yo most
of these guys are Petty most of these
guys are Petty and they're ego driv
there's no and they ego driven I don't
really care about that I I I did my
thing I'm working um and I've always
been this way I've never been Petty and
um I tell people that if someone steals
your
joke actually call that person as a man
and say yo you we you doing my bit and
let me um tell you how it's exactly like
my or I saw you at my show and you saw
me do that which is even worse is even
worse cuz now you're being disrespectful
um but to actually go on air and say
someone stole my joke because it's not
their set well we've seen people like
really have their careers hit a wall
because of the joke stealing thing yes
but let me tell you what I mean I'm glad
you're bringing this up there's a
difference between a set and a joke okay
your set is what you do for 60 minutes
right that's your that's your whole
that's your whole no one's stealing that
right someone stole a one minute joke so
if you had 15,000 in the bank right and
someone stole $1,000 at that 15,000
you're not going to get rid of the rest
of the money right so I can't tell
another comic what he should be mad
about my purpose of these interviews
that I'm doing is to give people another
way to see
something okay what is a joke and
people's like oh you stole this joke and
they make it say you you stole this
whole show but actual you just throw a
joke you then steal the set a joke don't
make you your set makes
you why um don't you film your sets for
social media like other comedians are
doing one is because I don't want other
Comics to see it and two there's Magic
on stage with me there is do you agree I
agree there's magic I agree and I don't
want to see it again because every time
there's a new beginning every show that
I do it's a different show and if you
see one if you see your set guess what
you're going to try to repeat that again
so I take what I do and track and
anything in life when I ran track and I
was
good just because I was good last week
don't mean I'm be good this week so I
took that through my whole life and just
because I was funny when you saw me that
don't matter no more can I be funny
tonight but you got to find different
ways to like say when if you had to be a
boxer right right if you're a boxer you
know you could beat this person but you
know what today I'm
tired I can't deliver that same energy
or the audience is different but if you
still find a way to be clever still find
a way to be funny
entertaining yeah work in the crowd
sitting in front you you were clowning
on these guys in the front row these
young that was hilarious oh my God it
was hilarious and long as the people
walk out into entertained right you were
hilarious so I think the other end of
that is or the other side of that coin
is if I saw you do what you did to those
kids yes that were sitting in the front
row that there was three single young
men right um if I saw that on Tik Tok or
or on Instagram and I didn't know who
you were right I'd be like yo I need to
follow this guy cuz that was great and
then I might be inclined to go see you
live absolutely cuz there are some
comedians who do do crowd work and they
show that but when you go see them
they're not that funny because that's
not the same situation that's going to
happen that night true cuz the crowd's
always going to be different it's always
going to be different cuz like you see
like uh have you heard of Matt re no I
haven't so Matt re uh he's doing like he
he's had a very like insane come up the
last 12 months okay so he has he has a
Netflix special but he blew up off of
his crowd workk bits going viral on his
Instagram and on and he's a good-look
young dude okay oh I know somebody used
to manage him okay yeah just talking
about him last time good looking young
guy and but he's very much new and I
mean it's a meteoric kind of rise in the
comedy world I've heard other comedians
talk about it like you know like it's
kind of unparalleled how fast he's come
up yes cuz he didn't have to go through
the bumps and bruises of you know
performing for 10 people right and and
before you even tell me what happens I
could tell you what how his career is
when you watch him M I bet you he's not
that funny well I saw it standable it
was it was it was it was okay yeah it
was mediocre because not that he won't
be funny right he hasn't put the time
in to be a great comic you need years of
experience you have to experience life
you have to go through things that's why
when you saw Richard prior he talked
about his drugs his situation what made
it funny cuz he was living life if
you're 20 something years old you ain't
lived right you talking about sneakers
and condoms maybe and smoking a little
weed but you haven't lived and when you
have lived then you have experience
after experience after experience gives
you more material it's almost like if
you're once you're a rapper it's like
once you hit a certain level of success
it gets harder and harder to draw
inspiration to make music that is
relatable to the people absolutely
because you're older now and rapping
believe it or not is a young kid game
right it's it's almost like when Jay-Z
did 444 it was like oh [__] right he
made like an album for like a
40-year-old [__] who's like
doing grown man [__] which is hard to do
and it be accepted yep yeah so true so
that's how that the game is but um it's
good to see from when I started in 1985
it's good to see so many different ways
you can make it in this business like
the gentleman you talking about or a
crowd work um it's also great to see
that the audience
the fans are starting to tell what is a
gimmick I feel like the gimmicks are
going going away it's about the is it's
about the jokes yeah it's about the
quality because they're getting tired of
being played that the I saw you on Tik
Tock you was hilarious and I come to
your show I spent
$175 $200 and I I didn't get what I
wanted out of your show it's like 50
Cent 50 Cent is go on these world tours
and all these young rappers can't do are
canceling they gotta cancel tour they
canceling it I saw I went to the 50 tour
and I was like you know I've been to
shows that were better I've been to
shows that I as a younger man you know
as a younger hip-hop fan but I don't
remember a show in the last 10 years
that I was
more just I just had such a good time
wow I was like gives a great show 50 is
an amazing performer and he's like we
don't like like that era we don't get to
see those guys tour right that's so true
anymore right y so it's like you know to
get a 50 Cent tour where he's doing get
rich or die trying and and and it's just
like it just took me back it was like
you know like we don't get those mega
mega mega hip like you were talking
about the Cash Money ref rer story like
the days of that [__] is like people are
it's like I feel like everything feels
like a cash grab yeah I totally agree
and that's sad yeah and even in the
comedy world it's a cash grab people
that come to your show like I don't
charge to take pictures after the show
I've seen that yeah and people will
charge you all that money a meet and
greet a meet and yeah you you charging
them for meet and greet that's a cash
grab and it's deeper than that to me
yeah it's deeper than that I'm saying
thank you let me shake your hand and
I'll see you next time I'll see you next
time I want to hold you I want to hug
you because I want you to come back and
I want you to know I appreciate you
spending your hard earned money to come
see me you had to go get a babysitter
you had to tell somebody um you'll be
back in a few hours you're going to go
see TK Kirk I understand all that I
don't want to rob you like that you know
I want to charge you for my tickets give
you a great show and have them leave the
same way give you a memory you take a
picture exactly you know so that was it
and you were so genuine cuz you know you
can look someone in their eyes and when
you came out of the show you I just saw
it in your face like you was truly
pleased for sure yeah you know and
that's what I love yeah that was I mean
like I said dude I I like going to the
store sometimes cuz I'll be able to
watch like 10 guys right I'll be able to
eat wings have drinks maybe like three
of the 10 I'll love you know but to like
sit down and just be like oh [__] this I
feel like I just went to church right
yeah I was I I get on it I get on it and
like I said I dropped the knowledge then
you saw the fun then you saw the
personality then you saw the
appreciation meaning shaking your hands
afterwards saying thank you like a p
for sure that's what it was hey we got
to stop the interview to tell you about
our good folks want to give a shout out
to odd Soxs that's right baby go to odd
Soxs official.com they just celebrated
10 years 10 years of odd Soxs that's
right use the promo code bootleg right
now you'll get 20% off all right look
they got all the socks they're the most
comfortable socks in the world though I
actually like to point out that that's a
fact uh well it's also factually my
opinion but I am telling you you won't
find a more comfortable sock than odd
Soxs now the real key is guys the odd
Sox Basics these right
here these are the only socks on my feet
if you saw me on on NBA young boys couch
with some wet dusty ass snow ridden sock
it was a white Odd Socks
basic the most comfortable sock in the
world they got all the licenses they got
[__] Crush they got Baja Blast be and
Butthead Hot Cheetos Modello I mean uh
Scarface we can go on and on and on they
got the underwear they got it all look
if you like A1 steak sauce they got a
pair of draws for that ass go to oock
official.com right now use the promo
code bootleg save 20% off a check out
thank me later also want to give a big
shout out to the good folks of King pal
that's right baby if y'all don't know
about King palom let me tell you about
King pom bro first of all we're talking
about straight raw organic goodness hand
me a box Cyrus hand me a a box give me a
box oh my goodness look what's dope
about King pom is no tobacco straight
organic natural Leaf all right oh we got
more oh we got more oh these are the
dragon fruit King sizes Jesus Christ how
much King P my [__] God just King
Palms listen that's all we smoke out of
right and they got the turpine infused
tips with that flavor listen bro the
flavor let me just show you what that
looks like like this right here here is
some of that blue
grape you know you light that up you
maybe put put some of your favorite
premium uh whatever you want in there
you know you light it up you got the tip
you squeeze that bad boy you're getting
hit with a rush of flavor um and right
now 50% off when you go to King pom.com
and use the promo code bootleg they got
Grinders they got uh what else do they
got they got goddamn ashtrays they got
all the all the King Palm leaves in the
world my favorite though right now I do
love the sugar Shan the sugar Shan honey
orange is fire all right 7-Eleven you
can go get King pom at 7-Eleven you go
to your local lior liquor store and load
up on King pom it's a clean way to smoke
it's a great way to smoke it's a natural
way to smoke tobacco free straight Leaf
in it um I will never smoke out of
anything but a king pom for the rest of
my life all right so shout out to King
pom go to kingp pom.com one more time
promo code bootleg save 50% off at out
half off what are we talking about let's
get back to the interview what would be
the advice you would give uh let's say
there's a stand up it just started
they're going to open mics trying to
improve their trying to improve the
craft you know it it feels like a very
very uphill battle to break through to
actually kind of eventually make money
that's so true you know yeah you're
right you're right I guess I guess what
for you would be the advice you would
give because it's it's this is not a
Sprint no you got to know who you are
and Paul Mooney said it best when I
first started and I was asking him
questions just like that and he said TK
um there's no substitute for
experience you got to put the work in 40
years ago this would have seemed like a
lifetime right it's like the 10,000
hours thing exactly like you can't cheat
the work and then you and if I could
tell people if you if you know how to
handle your own business try to handle
your own money try to book your yourself
um if you coming to someone and you're
funny start booking out your own venues
and and get a team and you could really
sell your your own tickets and go to
certain cities and book yourself but
people go they get an agent and agents
some agents just robbing the kids they
don't understand it you know we talk
about teraji um Henderson who is it
Henderson or H hon hon yeah and um how
she did a movie the budget was 167
million but she only got 150,000 of you
ain't even in that business but you know
that ain't a fair deal no that's crazy
for sure you know that ain't a fair deal
especially when you are in the top three
co-stars has Cube ever tried to put you
in something here's the thing about Cube
mentioned that earlier and I need people
to know something Q put a lot of people
on tons Chris Tucker
Cat Williams Cat Williams my GS but I
want everybody to know that Easy E and
Ice Cube I was their first
comic their first out of everybody I was
their first because they found me in
1988 these other kids these other guys
15 16 years old they took me on the
first tour Straight Out of Compton the
thing that I didn't do like most
comedians I didn't go Hollywood I didn't
want to audition I didn't want want to
do TV everything I did from Bal blocking
to New Jersey drive to Ben diesel movie
Strays I was invited to do I was invited
got my money because that person truly
wanted me My Philosophy
was I think it's difficult to go to do
an
audition true you know you're good for
that part but there's 40 4,000 men going
after the same part you are going after
and you got to take a chance to do that
I never had that kind of time I I came
up as a hustler you're shooting you're
really shooting shots hoping one goes in
eventually to get aart that's it and
yeah you could be great but maybe this
person had a bigger name than you and
that person was nowhere near your talent
right but because of politics they gave
it to that person well it's almost like
when you were originally coming up it
was all about trying to get on TV right
if you're right if you're
comedian I never wanted to do a sitcom I
had somebody approach me about doing a
sitcom this weekend oh really yeah
because you not do this thing called um
homeowners association you know and they
was like you said that's what you said
you said I'm president of the Home oners
Association and they said TK that's a
great TV show and I it is though it is a
great TV show but the thing about what I
know understand
reality blacks on TV is not the move
really oh no no no
no it's hard to have all black show on
ABC some of the best CVS shows are all
back in the 90s it was blackish was
solid Anthony Anderson yeah that's very
rare think about it for a second that's
very rare I like top boy top Boys on now
think about what I'm about to tell you
we might get one black show
now years the Shy's good though yeah on
Showtime yeah that's not a comedy though
no you talk about comedy yeah just talk
about it's comedy I feel like those
shows are I feel like unfortunately like
comedy sitcoms are just like dying it's
died it's more the reality TV shows have
replaced
sitcoms and and and it's cheaper to
produce way cheaper to produce so
everything now is cheaper to
do but the person who's putting up the
money is walking away with a lot more if
they did a
sitcom I just never wanted to get caught
up
in bad
negotiation I never want to get caught
up in not feeling I was getting paid my
worth I have to prove something TK do
that and then we could get you I've
already proven myself I'm not doing that
like myself self worth isn't determined
on whether or not and and and I haven't
really done TV and I got a little bit
more paper than people that done it
right but I've done it myself I cut out
the middleman it's like my man on um
American gangster what's his name you
talking about uh frankz Frank Lucas
Frank he cut out the middleman right
I've cut out the
middleman so but but this the thing
right because I feel like the other way
to look at it would be if you are if you
can if you can get a successful TV show
again that's a big if because most shows
only last one to two seasons and other
can and that's the thing if you can if
you can the royalties if you can get
seven years you you got a cash cow for
the rest of your life cuz cuz it's cuz
the reruns are going to pay it's the
reruns right but it's very slim
especially now maybe in the 9s you had a
better chance right now it's way harder
now it's way harder you got to kind of
do more of a serious show or like a
hybrid like drama SL comedy but I'm
going to try to do um I got something in
the works with Tim story Tim story done
all the major movies back in the day the
um um um a couple Marvel movies Etc U
he's a young brother that I met in
Chicago before he got famous and as you
know I've met everybody right so he's
one of my guys and I caught his
attention because of my Instagram and he
said
TK just like you he
said the way you tell a story your
presence he said I got to do something
with you so um he's also one of the guys
that uh might direct my special for
Netflix cuz cube is probably going to
turn it down but um but out of respect
out of respect I just want to share that
with them because before all this got to
where it was it was TK Kirkland number
one on the list in hip-hop and that's
what I wanted the world to know too
because I was the original hip-hop
comedian when I started there was nobody
doing them tours right yeah cuz you kind
of PVE the way for guys like Alex Thomas
who did y y and Alex is my man you know
Alex came to when Alex started doing
stand up Comer he came to actually talk
to me like I was that guy
to and I explain to him and the rest of
History doing well and I love that I had
something to do with that what was it
like being in baller blocking which is a
hood classic obviously Baler blocking
was amazing um and that all happened
because of Jay-Z and
Nelly yeah because I was on that hard
knock life tour and not the Hard Knock
Life tour there was another tour that
Nelly and then was doing I was on
thatour I forgot the name of it and um
no it was Jay-Z it was Jay-Z Rock the
mic tour yeah it was rock it was rock
rock the mic tour in New Orleans okay
and baby and them was there and um baby
walked up to me it was the Sprite remix
tour yeah whatever it was it was the
Sprite remix tour it was Nelly and Jay-Z
it was I think it was the Sprite tour
yeah Nelly was on it Jay-Z was on it and
I was the host of that too yeah and baby
walked up to me and you know how they
talk he said what up W yeah he said
listen I'm doing this movie called ball
of blocking and the rest is history and
I got to um en enjoy his energy because
he was you know he had just came into a
lot of money and he was shopping not for
one
person he was shopping for 15 20 people
shopping clothes and I remember me my
homie was withing I remember at one time
he bought four Bentley at one time at
one time so it he was so generous and in
the in in in that era that I feel like
before like scamming was popping to get
four Bentley is crazy yo and this is
when Bentley really first came
so that was a it was truly a a massive
statement if you had a Bentley it you
can see a Bentley now rolling around La
or Vegas yeah but then 1998 nobody had
Bentley nobody yeah so we're all in the
I remember like guess we was all in the
car dealership and he's buying the cars
and you know how sometimes you don't
look at someone they might just be in a
good mood and pick you yeah so I told my
home yo don't look at him he might get
us a car you know so turn Face we get us
a car but you know it didn't happen but
that been funny it was hilarious that's
how generous um baby is so you know I
can always say that about him uh I
appreciate your perspective on uh the
dichotomy between men and women and
relationships and I have to ask you uh
I'm going to present a scenario to you
okay and I want your take on it yeah
okay let's say
you're 50 years old s yes
you get divorced
yes within uh oh let's say you meet a
young lady who's 31 mhm right you're 50
she's
31 four to five weeks later you're with
this young lady and you have decided to
get her name tattooed on your body four
to five
times wow that's that's that's insane
okay yeah that's insane because you're a
free man finally you're a free man but
what most men do they look for the most
difficult thing to do in their life they
instead of taking an easy route most men
will go down a path of difficulty and
set themselves up for pay again and some
people maybe unnecessary stress un
unnecessary stress because if you're
50 and you got a girl that's 30 she
still hasn't lived yet so all you can do
is you know you dick her down you take
her shopping she feels good and she's
still a child right 31 she hasn't lived
MH so in today's world that's called a
simp in a sense because these girls
don't M they don't respect a man like
that at my that's if it was a 60
something year old woman or like even a
45y old oh 45 a 31 with the way the
world is today just to have that they on
the phone talking about the man who
they're pretty you pretty much using
like oh yeah he brought me this he
brought me that yeah you know because
like a woman who's like actually
understands the way the world Works
already would look at somebody who would
get four tattoos on their body in a four
weeks of their name and be a little
absolutely so he's something wrong with
him he's crazy he's a
psycho yeah my man I know you're talking
about and and and and and the thing and
the thing that I wanted to make sure I
know he's here he's here ladies and
gentlemen I didn't I didn't want
to
change who I was with my answers no this
is the answer yeah because right because
I could have easily lied and been
something else cuz I know he's here to
hear it he needs to hear it cuz I've
been trying to tell him this yeah you
don't you you you don't you no no no fam
we don't do that I'm saying this by
myself no no no no no no I'm sorry you
know but the thing is
that
you you have to learn how to enjoy life
and you got to love yourself so much yes
you got to love yourself yeah I think s
so so this is the thing right this why
I've been telling a lot of people in
general I just told it to to uh my guy
right here uh Cyrus your
selfworth and how you feel about
yourself can never depend on anything
that anyone else controls you will lose
if you do it way if you wake up in the
morning and your your happiness is
determing on what a b or c feels about
you or how like you you're going to lose
in
and when you date someone that young
you're really you're really destroying
their life and let me exp to what I
mean when a man knows he's dating a
younger woman you're really stopping her
growth in life cuz a a a real G is baby
you're too young I want you to explore
life you got to bump your head you have
to go through things like I give you
this dick yeah but and a motivational
speech right but that's all I can give
you because I'm I I care about you so
much I don't want to take away your
experience and here's one of the things
I use I always talk about trying to date
me is like trying to get into Harvard
everybody's not going to get accepted
you have to have experience and Life to
appreciate the kind of man that I am
because if you don't have no experiences
you have no idea the gift that you have
right here but if you bumped your head
through life a few times a few times and
then you meet a successful man right who
has benefits who can contribute to your
life you going to appreciate cuz when I
was young I used to I've always been
successful and I've been through stages
I've taken care of the men's kids I
bought women cars di I've been through
all and the thing that I remember one
time I always wanted to have somebody
who was
struggling because you could save them I
could save them yeah cuz that made me
feel good yeah we having problems let me
take let me let me help hey y your
daycare got it I got it that made you
feel good for sure for sure I've been
there when you grow
up and you really
understand it's not about you want a
woman to be physically beautiful of
course but what's your
character you want a woman to be
beautiful and what's your character but
what have you accomplish in your life
prior to meeting me because once you get
a certain age and I un see knowledge is
the gift and the curse marriage to me
unless you know who you are is for
people who don't understand life because
you go through all the dumb [__] but
when you knowledgeable you know how your
wife or husband is supposed to be or
your girlfriend or where supposed to be
know how to act open the door bring
things contribute to a relationship pour
into me as I pour into you as you get
old it's not about the body it's about
this word called sapio seexual can you
talk to me
and we have connection because as you
get older that's what makes sex better
because of the way a woman spoke to you
like oh my God baby I like what you said
you know there's some women that can
just motivate a man let's use Rocky when
he was getting his butt whooped Y and
his wife was in adri and he she said
come here he's like what she said come
here she said
when now he ran out of that damn house
started doing push-ups with one
arm for sure running up had logs on them
jumping up and down cuz this woman had
motivated him to a whole another level a
30 31 year old girl who walks around and
says that she's a woman because based on
the experiences that she has is not a
woman you you could only become a woman
with experiences and no matter what
you've gone through at 31 if you live
live to be
45 you're going to be swarter than you
was at 31 yeah if you live to be 60
something years old you're going to be
swarter than you was at 45 years old
true so life is this
great experience of experiences
turmoil pitfalls highes what age did you
decide if you're Petty if you show me
that P
I pull the plug I think it started in my
40s cuz I think in like I said if you
don't really know knowledge you don't
really have life experience you don't
know but then you start you get a girl
she argues with you about something you
have no idea what it is so now you
running out like you had a big argument
got you getting flowers you getting all
this kind of stuff because there's
something wrong with her and most men
don't take the time to figure it out
they they just deal with it they just
will deal with it just deal with it most
men are afraid to leave a cute girl cuz
they know they probably can't get
another girl they got lucky with this
one so they they snatch up or become
jealous or overp possessive because they
feel oh I I can't get no better than
this I'm here to tell any man about and
pl and
woman you can do better things happen
and see the universe to test you and
people don't understand the universe see
God will send you somebody well let's
say universe and that man or woman will
give you so much pain that pain is to
teach you to leave that person alone but
most people just take it but the
universe will keep giving I also feel
like what happens is you you get into a
POS a point in time where you feel you
start to feel responsible for the other
person that can happen to people as well
yeah you know especially if you if if
you was a um you're the
bag if you're the bag and you bring
somebody on then all of a sudden you get
tired if you put yourself in a position
where someone's struggling and you want
to do this and it's 3 or four years down
the road yes now you might feel bad if
you did and and as you get older you
want to have somebody that you don't
have to have a woman that put everything
in the pot no but something and here's
why if we break up we both emot both of
us going to be emotionally messed up for
sure but financially we should be messed
up too yeah because why said I spend
hundreds of thousands and we break up
I'm feeling pain and the financial
burden but all you said uh I got a new
car had some sex and you went on about
your
life it's just not fair hey we got to
stop the interview real quick man shout
out to our family at my bookie NFL
season is winding down you still got
some regular season uh games you can get
in on of course the college bowl games
are coming up so much money to get plus
the cash prizes going down in their
weekly Blackjack tournaments at
mybookie.ag and uh this is what's going
on right uh my bookie is crazy cuz
they're doing this if you sign up right
now at mybookie use the promo code
bootleg all right claim your deposit
match redeemable up to $11,000 that's
right they're going to match your first
deposit up to
$11,000 using the promo code bootleg
claim your bonus NFL college bowl gam so
much going on in terms of what you're
trying to get down with if you want to
gamble if you want to bet all right they
got Blackjack they got roulette they got
it all uh and of course the best odds
anywhere online when it comes to your
sports betting needs so one more time
sign up right now with that promo code
bootle um and I'm going to tell
everybody this uh you're going to get
your first deposit match up to
$1,000 I'mma put my money I'm feeling
good about the 49ers future BET right
now slam the ners to win the Super Bowl
I think they're taking that whole [__]
bet anytime anywhere with my bookie hey
um thank you for watching also shout out
to King pom geez I'm just swimming in
King pom but uh we got a shout out to
our good Folks at Blue Chu that's right
blue.com man New Year time to get that
uh that dick of yours in order maybe
you're dealing with the rectile
dysfunction stress at work maybe you're
married 30 years into the marriage it's
a little hard to get it up for old wifey
over there but you want to you know
smash her uh down take her to pound town
real quick for the anniversary what I
suggest you do is [__] with some
bluechew that's right blue Chu what is
it does it work first of all of course
it works yes it does work I've used it
it's great uh with that being said
bluechew it is the same active
ingredient as Viagra and seis all right
trust me oh they hit all right in a nice
chewable form yeah and it gets delivered
straight to your doorstep discreet
packaging you don't got to worry about
going to a doctor's appointment sitting
in an office and speaking with some
stranger about the issues with your
Johnson it's all online all online if
you're asking well I don't know man this
sounds like I don't I you know how much
is it what do we got to do to get it
look it's free that's right free you can
get your first month of bluechew for
free right now all right your dick
deserves it whoever's taking your dick
deserves it let's be honest all right so
go to blue.com use the promo code
bootleg right now and guess what your
first month will be delivered for free
all you got to do is pay $5 shipping
blu.com promo code bootleg get your
first month for free delivered right to
your doorstep and thank me later all
right let's get back to the interview
yeah I feel like too even on the other
like if you flip the coin like if you
are a woman or a man and you're with
your significant other and you truly
help them build their empire you kind of
take the back seat handle the kids
handle the house if that [__] goes
left I feel like it's kind of the other
party's duty to make sure that's a real
man yeah like I'm not going to leave you
with nothing like that's a real man yeah
like you without you I might not be here
right that that that's that's so true I
agree with that if if you got a woman
like that make sure you break off and
make sure she's straight yeah like me
and my wife started dating and I maybe
had six grand in my name she had like
300 Grand in the bank account we can
take this out but um but she like just I
don't know she just [__] with me you
know what I'm saying and listen I saw
the way she looks at you she's literally
kind of just held me down yeah but I I
I'm the kind of guy when I see an
attractive woman I know she's with
someone I don't look at her no more I
know you're lady is ATT tractor but I
had to take a a quick glimpse of her
like in the in the grocery store and you
scan her I couldn't look at it about
damn right but I know it was damn right
cuz I saw for a good that one second was
long enough to say yo he got good taste
and when you see a man with a beautiful
woman that means to me that your
confidence is on another level for sure
cuz when a man has a beautiful is is he
a liar cuz he lied to pull her and she
believed in him and she's still trying
to find out the stuff that you told me
and it didn't come along yet but she
she's still hoping to
believe but then it also
says you got to have the finest woman in
the room and that takes confidence for
sure confidence is important man yeah it
don't matter I always say it don't
matter how much money you got it don't
matter how you look if you got a plan
and confidence you got confidence and if
you can make a young lady laugh there's
yeah and and and and and you're a
goodlook guy and I can tell she loves
you yeah for sure your wife loves you
dog like you can see the energy when you
when you're together you can actually I
do think I do think I don't like the
fact that like there's this narrative
out there at times where if you get
divorced or you leave a situation and
you know that other person had a lot to
do with the foundation of making it
possible for you to go and do this this
or this right it's like you to me you
almost have that responsibility to like
if you're a decent person yeah if you're
a decent person if you're but most
divorces break up in bitter because the
man probably cheated cheating there
there's some heartbreak involved heart
emotions get involved ego gets involved
and that's when like yeah for sure
that's and that's what happens like if
you put a woman on she cheated on you
now you don't want to have nothing oh
yeah yeah for sure oh forget you you
kiss my ass it depends on how many kids
you got with him though cuz it's like
hey I need a place for my kids to sleep
listen I don't
care when some people are mad no for
sure done for sure done and then you got
people who will cheat on someone get
caught and then marry the person they
cheated on happens a lot and that and
they don't see that happens a lot and
they're miserable for the rest of their
life yep that's crazy now that happens a
lot I got I got a few of my friends you
got cheat on the baby I love you I'm
going to marry you and the girl accepts
it yeah but deep down in your heart and
your soul you're never the same right
you will ever every time that person
walks out that door you you have there's
a question mark a pain yep like I don't
know I don't always I you you know cuz
that Trestle no matter even if you want
to say it you trust them again you'll
never trust them never I've got a lot of
friends who are married they cheating
and I explain to them you know I I'll
I'll show a man how to cheat right
because I don't want you to get caught
cuz most men can't handle if they get
caught I told her do this the other day
I said dog you you messing around but if
you get cour you I already I can look at
you you ain't buil for what's about to
happen yeah like you got to have your
[__] air tight if you're going to I can
tell you yeah men
cheat and if they get caught this this
big embarrassment but it was but you got
caught that's the only reason why you
embarrassed right and then that woman
takes you through hell and then it takes
you out of your character now you're
crying you're crying you're getting all
violent you're getting weird you're
hitting you're punching window yes yes
yes you're doing stupid [__] a lot of
men to some point are hypocritical yeah
see if you're a
player that means your girl going to be
a playet cuz there is a word called
karma right and it does loop back around
sometimes at the worst moment you could
have been cheated your whole life but
your girl dealt with it now you're in a
wheelchair well you'll see situations
too where like you'll know somebody has
been cheating on their wife for years
and years and then obviously the
marriage isn't great she steps out once
and it's like he lost it like Bro you've
been [__] [__] this whole time and
ask you for your advice and come to you
crying yeah let me tell but in your head
you like yo hey like she got one off you
can't trip oh and to the people that's
listening if you cheat and then your
girl cheat and you can't take it say
baby let's stop this is this what you
what I'm feeling I don't want to feel
that again let's call a truce it's a
truce yeah I can't let's not do this no
more I'm sorry I'm sorry I now I feel
it that's so true man for sure that's so
true that's a pain that some people
cannot handle that's why you see
murderers yeah I got a homie of mine
who's going through like a separation
right now oh he can't deal with it well
he he never cheated he's he's a he's a
good guy but but he's older she's
younger um they're going through a
separation they're still friends but he
just found out she signed up for a
dating app and lost his [__] mind wow
and I told him I said bro like you got
to let her live she's been I mean he's
he's 40 something she's probably my age
and he's been with her since she was
like 20 yeah see so I was like Hey I was
like hey bro if she's yours it's going
to be fine right but like let her
breathe for a little bit like you guys
are still do is just be her friend
that's what I told him I said yo you
just got to pick up the phone go to the
movies every once in a while but if
she's going to go and do whatever she's
going to do just let her do it man yeah
you got to be a friend you got to say
call just to say hi yeah call just to be
a friend and you start dating
right you start dating because if you
really want to back here goes psychology
if you get a girl that's prettier oh and
that girl got she's doing well oh
brother unless you was a lunatic you was
beating her up and you just really
dogged her right yo she might she it's
possible she'll come back she'll come
right back it's possible possible for
sure um anything or because I obviously
you've been doing your podcast for a
while I wish you would do more video
content I know we talked about that the
last time I just don't have the time I
think that you if you were to pour into
your
podcast oh it' be insane I'm doing my
first live one though at the the day
before the Super Bowl in Las Vegas
Nevada with the NFL um we going to St
posting so I would love matter of fact I
would love for you to come so I can
interview you I'm down let's go yeah
that I would you yo I promise you I'm
I'll call them today and tell them to
put you on the list will ENT and they'll
reach out to you I think uh yeah I just
think that every time I see your Clips
I'm like man if you sat down and and did
kind of like your version of what like
Joe Rogan does and talk to comedians
friends about all oh yeah you can bring
on financial advisors just so much and
you can have conversations with people
that other people aren't capable of
having absolutely I totally agree and
this has always been at the table you
and other people
man it's a it's a seven figures on the
other side of that door easy yeah but
I'm rich I know I feel you it ain't
about the money to but but it also but
but for you you have like cuz this in my
my opinion if you did that it would free
up your bandwidth from the road but you
love the road I love the road it it
keeps me young cuz the road is it's it's
a lifestyle it's a lifestyle you know
Ritz Carlton Peninsula
hotels cuz you would have to ease up on
the road a little to really really yeah
and um um and um how can I say
it I don't want to bite off more than I
could chew and that's fair cuz if you
buy out more than you can chew and you
don't give it all that you know it
deserves to have and like I said I'm A
og you really have to manage your health
your time and your mind for sure and um
it's really a young man's game right and
um I like
peace I like peace if the you you
figured out your the road [__] so so you
know I know when I'm getting and and and
then when you want to interview
celebrities or whatever guess what you
get sometime
cancellations people who don't respect
your time no people can't they not going
to make it today they can't make it yeah
and you like you sometime can mess up
your thing or whatever no I think for
you like if you just had like just your
peers your comedy peers on yes yes yes
yes over I on my podcast now I just deal
with regular people and their situations
in life right I like that because they
always going to be there there a lot of
them celebrities schedule conflict TK
I'm sorry I can't make it right and
there's no jealousy there's no hatred
right you know if I had this and
somebody came in you never know they
they might be jealous whatever I'm one
of those people that people are jealous
of I've always just been that guy you
know
confident um know always had gorgeous
women always had money right that that
the same thing people love you for a lot
of people hate you for would you ever
open a comedy club nope too much
aggravation okay yeah too much
aggravation my life is about peace yeah
yeah I I I see that peace there's too
much stress got to get a liquor license
got to deal with somebody underage got
in somehow what the [__] you know Peace
of Mind security beat up uh one of our
openers now I got to deal with a lawsuit
you know yeah I want I want peace peace
and quiet um maybe in the next 10 years
you know I'm going go get a bigger house
for the grandkids have my son
because they'll be older so I have the
grandkids come stay at the house with me
um might have a sign true significant
other um so that's not out of the cards
for you still I won't get married but
I'll put a ring on a woman's finger to
let her know that I respect her this
like you're this is it yeah this is it I
don't have to marry you right here's the
ring but we're not going to go to the
courthouse and do this yeah here's the
ring and out of respect you know and I
always try to put people and you don't
have to get married but I'll maybe take
10,000 and put it in
annuity and then in 20 years that 10,000
is $20 something th000 yeah why would we
spend $100,000 on a wedding exactly
let's put that in annuity people need to
understand annuities and stuff so I'll
take it on stage and being my age too
like it's insane because I got the women
from now they 24 25 years old holling at
me and I got to talk to him on the phone
sometime and explain to him I'm too old
to date you and some of them fine right
but I the way I get out of it I would
say my daughter would kill me that's
what I say and it's impossible for you
to have like a real emotional connection
with someone that young I feel like I
don't even want to deal with that yeah
that aggravated [__] don't get me wrong
some of these girls and deal with the
arrogance of a girl that's that young
who thinks that they can hang with like
yeah like you sweetheart
no even if you're 40 something you
almost still out of my league in the
sense C I'm 63 right that's 20 year
difference yeah you still are going to
grow so
much from 40 to 60 years old you're
going to be night and
day when you get to be my age if I date
you at 40 something years old night and
day true night and day so if I meet
someone in their 40s my goal is to be to
give you knowledge bring great things
out of you that I see know how to talk
better to the that you might date
somewhere down the line in life um know
how to move so when you do meet this
other guy maybe you met a guy that gave
you the game on how to be a a better
version of yourself that's beautiful man
uh before we go how you stay so young
man what are we doing what's the what's
the diet what's the you just all the
things that we talked about I'm not
married I don't have no
stress I I take time I work out every
other day okay so you're still working
love my grandkids oh yeah definitely
careful about what you're eating care
about what matter fact I lost W since
the last time yall see me so I think I
lost about 15 20 pounds but I still feel
big you know but
um Kev I'm happy fam I hope when people
see me what they see is man he's really
happy like I'm happy and when I do think
about dating I go man when you date
you're give
someone the power to make you unhappy
even just 5 minutes of that day yep and
my whole day is happy yeah my whole not
not half the day the whole day the whole
day but if you get with someone it's a
possibility that five minutes that hour
that whole day maybe a week will have
you shifted off your square and I just
love life so much I mean I love this
thing I don't want nothing to mess it up
nice cigars fly whips yeah nobody nobody
to answer to nobody to answer to listen
appreciate you give some of
the great interviews man thank you TK I
and I watch our interviews after we and
I watch you for a whole year and I
always put you on my calendar for the
following year like you're one of those
guys I always look forward to coming to
talk to a year it gives me something to
think of like you when I walk out this
door I will already be thinking for the
next
365 days about you cuz I watch you I see
your stuff that you do I watch your
interviews and I go you know I'm really
and then Aris keeps me um up on you too
he said you're doing really well and
they adding more shows to your your show
your radio station we're like at 70 some
OD cities now that's great yeah it's
crazy that's great you know we just
picked up yeah it's crazy so how's your
relationships now with sponsors you
still got great relationship with
sponsors yeah yeah I uh so with the
podcast is separate from the radio show
mhm the radio show
is the business model is
essentially I get inventory m in every
Market I'm in yes and then the company I
work with sells that inventory okay um
and then we divvy that up right so cuz
the reason why I asked that question I'm
a businessman see I got my deal with
Live Nation but I want to bring a
sponsor on yeah so my sponsors for the
podcast Harden which is in Vegas um King
pom LRG whatever I deal with all those
directly yeah I want to bring on a
sponsor for my L Nation Tour yeah I mean
there's definitely that's the thing is
like I think most
people think of sponsors and they're
like it seems like a big mountain to
climb I'm talking about like independent
podcast like all the people who I've
reached out or who I have as P podcast
sponsors I mean we have blue Chu which
is the dick pills they reached out to me
m um they all were the first four or
five were all just people I had
relationships with yes so like Harden
like I'm cool with the owner Adam and DJ
bonx and LRG clothing my friend's been
the head of marketing there forever so
yeah I mean you could easily do that so
and here's business see we do the deal
together you're agent on the deal yeah
I'm doing this for the next 10 years you
smoke I smoke a little bit okay but I do
my smoking like a player right and I'm
expl to what that means in a room with a
woman bottle of ace of spray of Louis
the 13th and you sitting there on the
balcony overlooking a pool ocean and you
got your girl with you you got your
stuff ready and you smoking with each
other yeah you know not smoking in your
car driving down the street yes your car
smells like [__] every time people get
into it not smoking in out in the
hallway to mess up a presidential s
right like people don't do stuff with
class and you know I do stuff with class
I got the champagne there we sitting
back like cigar in in my pajamas so the
is the Live Nation Tour something you're
working on for this year oh no I got it
we start in April oh so it's coming in
April yeah yeah we we make the
announcement in the minut so I got to
ask cuz like are the smaller shows you
do across the country are
those working up material for so the
clubs that you came to see me cuz you
did two or three shows those um shows
have been booked for the last 3 four
years right I know what I'm doing I took
on the Live Nation thing cuz I wanted
people to see growth right right so the
sign with Live Nation was like Wow TK
yeah doing his thing and um I'm a little
tired so I I hand it over certain
markets to Live Nation so I don't have
to worry about going to those markets
all I got to do is go get on the mic
tell the joke get money and go home but
what I explained to them that I wasn't
going to do you wasn't going to put me
in three cities
back to back cuz I know my age that'll
wear you down so we do some cities one
show that weekend maybe two shows in the
same night but never I'm going to be in
Chicago on Friday in Detroit on well
that's that's too close Seattle the day
yeah yeah no no no yeah yeah that's then
Miami yeah with travel and then time
changes and I ain't doing that yeah no
that's great not doing that because you
got to know your body you got to stay
healthy and and
um yeah let's put that deal together
I'll make sure I'm put I'm make sure
you're the agent on the deal okay all
right so where you get a check too I'll
see if I can make something sh see we
make happen and um and it's it's a
definite done it's a deal it's done and
the Netflix special on the way the
Netflix special is going to do in 2025
it's already in the works and I want to
do something different I want to um it's
almost to what Chris Rock and Kevin Hart
did but I want to do mine through
hip-hop yeah cuz I came up through hip
hop right so I want the people that I
open up for to for them to take clips of
them and talk about how I used to rock
that would be dope cuz it's it's a
special but it's also kind of like a a a
documentary bio that's what I want I
want that type of interview because I I
know that I'm unique and my standup is
special and I came up in the game a
different way and to show that have 50
Cent they have Jay-Z they have um
baby L Wayne those guys talk about TK
it's big deal do you think last thing
because you mentioned Kevin Heart I
always wonder this m i feel like somehow
he's be gets too much hate now for some
reason when you're number one yeah cuz I
used to feel the same way where I'd be
like a Kevin Hart's kind of overrated
but it's like at this point it's like
this guy works his ass off he and he
went through the gauntlet of yeah people
that's not what people look
at people look at competition and when
you're
competition people throw dots they did
it to Michael Jordan they do it to Tom
Brady everybody when you get there
everybody Jay-Z F whoever whoever get
gets that moment everybody else is
shooting for you it's like being
Philadelphia um Eagles Eagles you was
champion last year right this whole
season everybody was gunning for you
that's we call that competition
right but on the streets we'll say
that's they a hater but no they just
trying to knock you up your throne the
same thing in real life when you become
number one it's like in radio you if
someone knew that you had the number one
podcast radio show and the other person
is five and they know about you their
goal is to actually knock you out your
number one spot right it's always about
competition this what I meant to talk
about last night now I think about it
it's always competition like give me the
female and she'll say I'm not going to
compete to get you and I tell people all
the time that competition is what made
the world why you think they create the
Super Bowl right right if you drive down
the street you'll see Wendy's across the
street and Burger King right across
they're in competition if you got
someone that's in competition that means
you will always stay on your queue when
you watch the foods that built America
and you think about how they created the
Oreo cookie when you think about um
kellock Frosted Flakes and how they went
up against um Rice Krispies right all
this was competition
all is competition so competition brings
the best out you yeah it's just that in
the real world when people throwing DTS
at Kevin Hart but in actuality what they
really trying to do is how can I how can
I get what he has exactly I really want
to be where he is I want to be number
one yeah that's what I gathered mostly
from that Cat Williams interview yeah
was he feels like he should be where
Steve Harvey is oh absolutely that's
exactly what that is and there's no
secret society and there's no secret to
me like Steve Harvey however you feel
about him like he obviously my friend
produces His Radio Show he's been a part
of his radio show for a long time and
from what I hear he is one of the
hardest working people I vouch for this
I've been Steve Harvey came up probably
a little bit after me that's a
hardworking man yo yeah Steve Harvey and
he's disciplined and he's disciplined I
don't I I've heard a lot of things about
his personal life but that's not what we
talking about here we talking about his
how he works don't know can't nobody out
work now I work I think he got me beat
by a little bit Yeah cuz he'll do the
Radio Show in the morning and he'll have
to film the TV show and he's got so much
going on that's I wouldn't even want all
that headache it's a lot because you
know everybody's shooting for the bag
but one things I always say that's
important is not how well you live is
how well you
die
see in a 100 years nobody will Care
About Us in 100 Years everybody in this
room will be gone and only thing you
have left is
things and nobody cares and that is a
perfect way to end the interview my man
bar can we show some love to our family
at harden man shout out to harden man
look if you're in Vegas you got to pull
up you got to say take me to harden
right now I need to go to harden they're
going to take you they're G to get you
situated Harden Las Vegas the best
cannabis uh dispensary I've ever walked
into in my life the most craziest
selection of Premium cannabis in the
entire world I mean that place smells
like
God's uh sweat it feels it just smells
so good in there it's just oh they got
their own scent they're our family too
man so make sure you follow them online
Harding Vegas all right shoot them a
follow on uh Instagram also go to Hardin
vegas.com and when you're in Vegas make
sure you pull up to harden baby